♪ ♪ ♪
>> WE BEGIN WITH ANOTHER
DEVASTATING NATURAL DISASTER IN
NORTH AFRICA, JUST DAYS AFTER
THE DEADLY EARTHQUAKE IN
MOROCCO LIBYA IS NOW COPING
WITH MAJOR FLOODING THAT'S
WIPED OUT MAJOR VILLAGES AND
REPORTEDLY KILLED THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
VIDEO FROM THE REGION, YOU CAN
SEE IT THERE, SHOWS BUILDINGS
COLLAPSED, CARS SUBMERGED,
TORRENTS OF WATER RUSHING
THROUGH THE STREETS.
THE LIBYAN NATIONAL ARMY AND
HEALTH OFFICIALS SAY MORE THAN
2000 PEOPLE ARE DEAD, 5 TO 6000
MISSING.
OF COURSE, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
VERIFY THOSE NUMBERS, AS MANY
AREAS ARE STILL UNREACHABLE AND
WITHOUT COMMUNICATION.
THE CITY OF DERNA WAS
ESPECIALLY HARD HIT.
AUTHORITIES SAY TWO COLLAPSED,
THREE BRIDGES WERE DESTROYED,
AND PHONE LINES REMAIN DOWN.
THE STORM SYSTEM DUMPED ABOUT
EIGHT MONTHS WORTH OF RAIN IN
THE REGION IN JUST A SINGLE DAY.
AND THERE WAS CATASTROPHIC
FLOODING IN GREECE JUST LAST
WEEK.
THE PICTURES ARE JUST
STAGGERING.
WE GO LIVE NOW TO CNN'S ELENI
GIOKOS, WHO'S BEEN FOLLOWING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR US FROM DUBAI.
NOW SHOCKINGLY, THE HEAD OF
LIBYA'S EMERGENCY AND AMBULANCE
SERVICES ADMITTED TO CNN THAT
THERE WAS NO WARNING FOR PEOPLE,
NO WARNING TO EVACUATE, TO GET
TO HIGHER GROUND OR TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS COMING AT
THEM.
>> AND YOU KNOW THOSE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ALSO SAID THAT THERE
IS JUST LACK OF PREPAREDNESS,
THAT WEATHER CONDITIONS WEREN'T
STUDIED, THAT THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SEA LEVELS
RISING AND JUST WHAT THE STORM
COULD MEAN.
AND OF COURSE, MANY ARE ASKING
ABOUT NEGLIGENCE IN THE
SITUATION.
PEOPLE WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT WHEN THE STORM HIT
SEEING THEIR HOMES FLOODED,
SOME SAY UP TO THREE METERS.
AND THEY'RE DESPERATELY TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO GET OUT.
AND OF COURSE, WE'RE SEEING
THESE IMAGES OF WATER
EVERYWHERE.
CARS WERE SWEPT AWAY.
PEOPLE SWEPT AWAY.
SO MANY AREAS ARE NOW ISOLATED,
MAKING IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHO THEY NEED TO
SAVE AND WHAT IS THE NEXT
PROCESS.
I MEAN, SOME OF THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE TEAMS CAN'T EVEN GET
ACCESS AND COMMUNICATIONS UP
WITH TEAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ON THE GROUND.
SO, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A METS
CATASTROPHE HE.
EXACERBATING THE SITUATION, YOU
HAVE TWO DAMS THAT WERE BURST,
WHERE WE SEE NOW THE EPICENTER
OF THE BIG TRAGEDY IN THE CITY
OF DONNA.
AND THAT OF COURSE CAUSING MORE
PRESSURE WATER COMING THROUGH,
FILLING UP THE VALLEY, CAUSING
MORE CATASTROPHE.
WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU'VE GOT
ROADS AND HOMES THAT ARE
BASICALLY MELTING AWAY WITH
THIS WATER.
AUTHORITIES ARE TELLING US
THERE'S STILL BODIES LYING
AROUND.
SO WHEN WE SAY THE DEATH TOLL
NOW IS OVER 2000, DIFFICULT TO
ASCERTAIN THE NUMBER AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
BETWEEN FIVE AND 6000 PEOPLE
POLYCYSTIC MISSING.
YOU'VE GOT THE U.N. ON THE
GROUND, TURKEY, UAE, AS WELL AS
QATAR SENDING ASSISTANCE, STORM
DANIEL CAUSING HAVOC, NOT ONLY
NOW WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN LIBYA,
BUT ALSO IN GREECE AND TURKEY
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
AND NOW MOVING TOWARDS NORTHERN
EGYPT, THE NEXT TWO DAYS
THEY'RE EXPECTING AN EXTRA 50
MILLIMETERS OF RAINFALL.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF
RAINFALL THE CITY OF DERNA
HASN'T SEPTEMBER, A BARELY GETS
TO TEN MILITARY --
TEN MILLIMETERS.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NUMBERS
THAT HAVEN'T SEEN HIM FELT
BEFORE RIGHT NOW.
SEARCH AND RESCUE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO TRY TO GET
ACCESS TO PEOPLE.
PHONE LINES ARE DOWN, INTERNET
IS DOWN, POWER LINES ARE DOWN,
MAKING IT A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
TO KEEP AWAY.
>> I MEAN, LOOK, THE PICTURES
THAT WE ARE SEEING ARE SIMPLY
SHOCKING.
AND AGAIN, IT SEEMS THE
DEVASTATION IS WIDESPREAD.
ELENI, WHAT MORE CAN ANYONE DO
HERE IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
COORDINATE AID TO THIS COUNTRY?
I MEAN, LIBYA HAS BEEN IN
TURMOIL POLITICALLY FOR QU
SOME TIME NOW.
>> EXACTLY, IT HAS.
AND YOU KNOW, THE QUESTION IS,
IS THERE A CENTRALIZED SYSTEM
WHERE BOTH THE EAST AND THE
WEST CAN BE IN COMMUNICATION TO
FIGURE OUT THE NEXT STEPS HERE?
YOU'VE GOT TO REMEMBER THE EAST
IS CONTROLLED BY THE LIBYAN
NATIONAL ARMY, AND THE WEST IS
CONTROLLED BY INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZE GOVERNMENT.
BOTH OF THESE FACTIONS HAVE
BEEN VYING FOR POWER FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
SO CLEARLY, A DISCONNECT IN
COMMUNICATION HERE.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THE WEST HAS
DECLARED THREE DAYS OF
MOURNING.
CLEARLY THIS HAPPENING IN A
COUNTRY THAT HAS A LOT OF
POLITICAL TURMOIL.
BUT AT A TIME WHERE THEY NEED
TO COME TOGETHER TO FIGURE THE
NEXT STEPS HERE.
THE FACT THAT WE'VE ALREADY GOT
INTERNATIONAL COOPERATION IS A
STEP FORWARD.
BUT A LOT MORE, PAULA, IS
NEEDED, BECAUSE SEARCH AND
RESCUE IS STILL ON.
CATASTROPHE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT
TWO DAYS.
AND ON THE QUESTION THEN
BECOMES THE CLEANUP AFTER.
BUT OF COURSE, THAT WOULD BE
THE AFTERMATH OF THIS, AS YOU
SAY, APOCALYPTIC SCENARIO THAT
IS PLAYING OUT WHERE VILLAGES,
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DERNA
HERE, BUT YOU'VE GOT BENGHAZI
HERE, YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER CITY
--
BEING IMPACTED.
AND OTHER VILLAGES ARE BEING
ENTIRELY SWEPT AWAY AND
UNDERWATER AS WEAK.
>> YEAH, THIS WOULD BE LIKE A
LARGE STORM HITTING IN THE
UNITED STATES, LARGE HURRICANE,